J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, mais c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde, j'espère que vous allez bien. J'espère que vous avez passé un été reposant et ensoleillé parce qu'à présent, il est temps.
Il est temps d'ouvrir ce qui est déjà la sixième saison. Sixième saison, rendez-vous compte, de Septante Minutes Avec qui a cinq ans cette semaine.
Et pour ce faire, j'ai rencontré Vincent Lorant, qui est sociologue, spécialisé sur les questions de santé publique. Ça faisait un moment que je voulais le rencontrer.
Il est professeur à l'UCL, ici à Bruxelles, mais il m'avait répondu à l'époque qu'il n'était pas dispo parce qu'il était en Indiana.
Voilà, bon, ça arrive. Bref, je l'ai rencontré cette semaine et on a parlé ensemble de tabagisme.
Alors, pour ceux qui m'écoutent et qui sont fumeurs ou fumeuses, peut-être que vous vous demandez un peu de quoi on va parler, qu'est-ce qu'on va raconter, est-ce que ça va être moralisateur, désagréable à écouter, etc.
Concrètement, on a parlé ensemble de tabagisme, vraiment d'un point de vue sociologique, pour expliquer, par exemple, pourquoi c'est surtout les pauvres qui fument alors que, ben, ça coûte super cher.
On a cherché à comprendre un peu comment vient l'idée aux gens de fumer, etc. Sur ce, je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute.
J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Vincent Lorant. Bonjour Vincent.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes sociologue, politologue et économiste et professeur de sociologie médicale et de politique de santé à l'UCL.
On vous reçoit aujourd'hui pour parler de questions de tabagisme, en particulier chez les jeunes, et de politique de prévention.
Première question que j'ai envie de vous poser, c'est : qu'est-ce qui vous a amené, en tant que sociologue,
à approcher de ces questions-là en particulier, c'est-à-dire des questions de santé publique et plus précisément la question du tabac sur laquelle vous avez pu travailler ces dernières années ?
C'est une très bonne question. Au départ, j'étais pas particulièrement intéressé par les questions de tabagisme, mais j'y suis arrivé parce que le tabagisme, si vous voulez, est un facteur explicatif majeur
des inégalités d'espérance de vie entre les couches, différentes couches socioéconomiques d'une population.
D'accord. C'est explicatif plus que révélateur. C'est vraiment, c'est la cause centrale.
Non, c'est explicatif.
Oui.
C'est explicatif, hein. Donc il y a en Belgique une différence d'espérance de vie d'environ six ans, hein, entre les catégories les plus favorisées et les moins favorisées, plus faible dans les moins favorisées.
Et un des déterminants majeurs de ces différences, c'est la consommation de tabac, en fait, hein. Et donc, en fait, j'ai voulu expliquer un peu un paradoxe.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer que des populations modestes fument plus alors que, d'une manière générale, leur état de santé est déjà plus précaire à la base, mais surtout, le tabac, ça coûte énormément.
Oui, c'est ça.
Et donc ça, c'était un paradoxe qu'on a essayé d'expliquer dans la première vague de l'étude Sydney.
OK, mais effectivement, donc l'étude Sydney, c'est ça ?
Mmh.
Sur laquelle vous avez pu travailler ces dernières années, qui a eu lieu de 2013 à 2018, qui s'intéressait notamment au tabagisme chez les très jeunes, hein, écoles secondaires, et voilà, jeunes adultes.
On va effectivement s'approcher de ces questions de, ouais, comme vous le disiez, assez paradoxales, assez étonnantes.
Si on reprend les choses à la base et qu'on s'intéresse à pourquoi est-ce que les gens fument, avant de s'intéresser plus particulièrement aux questions, aux strates plus pauvres, plus riches et autres, et diviser ainsi notre société.
Concrètement, dans les pays occidentaux, il est depuis très longtemps interdit de faire la publicité pour le tabac, à la télévision et autres.
Malgré ça, si on cherche très fort, on peut trouver des vidéos internes aux sociétés de, voilà, aux sociétés qui vendent du tabac.
Je pense notamment à Marlboro, qui avait lancé il y a quelques années une campagne qui s'appelle Don't Be a Maybe, en anglais.
Et on voit dans cette vidéo interne, hein, qui n'a pas vocation à être vue par le grand public, que les valeurs de Marlboro sont les valeurs de liberté, d'authenticité et le fait d'être maître de sa destinée.
Et voilà, ils voulaient faire en sorte que les fumeurs comprennent mieux les valeurs que Marlboro représente en particulier.
Et ça, ça m'a amené à poser la question : qu'est-ce que les jeunes adolescents, lorsqu'ils observent des fumeurs autour d'eux, voient pour être séduits ?
Qu'est-ce qui est séduisant chez les jeunes adultes pour commencer à fumer ?
Je dirais que votre question, il faut la prendre par deux angles.
Mmh.
Il y a la question de l'initiation. Qu'est-ce qui fait que des adolescents se mettent à fumer ? On appelle ça l'initiation.
Et puis après l'initiation, il y a l'autre aspect du problème : qu'est-ce qui fait que des adolescents, des adultes continuent à fumer ?
Mmh, mmh.
Et en fait, on ne peut répondre à votre question qu'en les séparant, ces deux questions-là.
Bien sûr, oui. Donc ici, sur l'initiation en particulier.
Voilà. Sur l'initiation, en fait, ce qu'on sait, c'est qu'il y a aucun adolescent qui se lève le matin en disant : « Je vais me mettre à fumer », hein.
Ouais.
Mais il y a aucun adolescent qui se dit : « Je veux être plus libre », pour reprendre votre terme fort de Marlboro.
Maître de sa destinée, ouais.
Je vais être maître de ma destinée, donc je vais me mettre à fumer. Ce qu'on sait depuis maintenant plus de dix ans, c'est qu'en fait, les adolescents se mettent à fumer parce qu'autour d'eux, d'autres adolescents fument.
Mmh. D'accord.
En fait, la consommation de tabac, c'est essentiellement une contagion sociale, en fait, hein. Comme, ben voilà, je vous offre un verre d'eau, j'en prends un aussi.
Dans un café, on prend un verre de bière, l'autre le prend, etc. Le tabac, en fait, c'est essentiellement une contagion sociale.
Et donc en fait, ce sont des effets d'imitation ou d'influence, hein, qui sont assez complexes en termes d'interactions sociales.
Mais si je dois donner une réponse assez simple, c'est essentiellement en fait dans le contexte de l'apprentissage social en fait.
Je veux appartenir à un groupe et Dieu sait, chez les adolescents, appartenir à un groupe quand on a entre douze, treize, quatorze ans, c'est super important.
Et si ce groupe se manifeste par une prévalence plus élevée de consommation de tabac, je vais me mettre à fumer pour appartenir à ce groupe.
Donc c'est essentiellement un mécanisme d'influence et d'apprentissage social.
Donc il n'y a pas alors la notion de fameuse cigarette qui a l'air cool ou peut-être un peu quand même. Est-ce qu'il y a une notion d'esthétique ?
Est-ce que la cigarette rend cool finalement ? Ou bien est-ce que c'est strictement, même si on trouve que c'est dégueulasse, la contagion sociale fait que, voilà, on a envie de...
Le côté cool, c'est le côté du fait que ce comportement va me permettre de m'identifier ou de me rapprocher du groupe. Et l'appartenance au groupe est cool.
Mais c'est plus une conséquence sociale que un signal du comportement. Ou plus exactement, le comportement donne un signal
d'être cool parce que je suis dans un groupe qui fume ou parce que je veux me rapprocher d'un groupe auquel je m'identifie plus.
C'est ça.
Hein. Quand on fait maintenant des enquêtes auprès des adolescents, en général, ils sont extrêmement conscients de tous les risques et les aspects non cool du tabac, hein : l'haleine, les couleurs des doigts...
Des dents, ouais.
Une série de facteurs. En fait, ils savent que c'est pas cool.
D'accord, ok. Et qu'est-ce qui fait la différence alors entre les fumeurs occasionnels, hein. Je crois qu'en Belgique, on tourne autour de quatre pour cent, selon les chiffres qui sont disponibles, quatre pour cent de personnes.
Et c'est assez stable, hein, sur les vingt, vingt-cinq dernières années.
Ouais.
Environ quatre pour cent de fumeurs occasionnels. Qu'est-ce qui fait la différence entre les personnes qui sont des fumeurs occasionnels et les fumeurs réguliers, quotidiens ?
Ça, c'est principalement lié au deuxième aspect dont je vous parlais, c'est-à-dire la rapidité et en même temps la force de dépendance qui est derrière la nicotine.
En fait, vous avez des personnes qui vont fumer, mais qui ne vont pas devenir très dépendantes pour des raisons principalement génétiques, biologiques, et qui vont pouvoir s'abstenir de fumer, hein.
Une des questions, si vous voulez, qui permet de mesurer le plus facilement la dépendance d'une personne au tabac, c'est quand vous vous réveillez combien de temps avant la première cigarette ?
Il y a des personnes, ils se réveillent et avant le café, ils ont besoin d'une cigarette. Il y en a d'autres qui vont attendre d'être en chemin pour le boulot.
Donc en fait, certaines personnes sont très rapidement et fortement dépendantes, d'autres sont moins rapidement dépendantes et d'autres restent relativement peu dépendantes.
Les fameux fumeurs occasionnels dont vous parlez, en fait, c'est des personnes qui, pour des raisons—
à mon avis, un mix d'histoire de consommateur et de vulnérabilité génétique, sont beaucoup moins dépendants à la consommation de tabac.
Il y a un facteur de l'ordre, je pense, de trente pour cent d'héritabilité dans la dépendance au tabac, hein.
Et donc vous évoquiez cet aspect voilà, génétique, la question de l'accoutumance, la dépendance à la nicotine.
Attention. Un facteur génétique dans la rapidité et la force d'accoutumance.
C'est ça, oui.
Pas dans le fait de vous mettre à fumer, hein.
Bien sûr, bien sûr, bien sûr, oui. On parle de cette deuxième étape qu'on disait, ce deuxième stade. Concrètement, quand on va les interroger, eux, sur : Tiens, pourquoi est-ce que vous fumez ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que vous continuez à fumer alors que, voilà, comme on sait, c'est terriblement nocif. Souvent, la question du stress va être évoquée.
Ouais.
Et la cigarette va être évoquée comme étant quelque chose de terriblement soulageant qui fait du bien, ça détend, etc.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité là-derrière ou est-ce que...
Non, mais non, mais non, c'est le sevrage, en fait. C'est le syndrome du sevrage, en fait. Donc, vous fumez, donc en fait, vous réduisez votre anxiété.
L'anxiété qui est causée...
Qui est liée au sevrage, en fait.
Voilà. L'anxiété qui est causée par le manque.
Ben oui.
La dépendance.
Bien sûr. Donc en fait, si vous voulez, ils mélangent la cause et l'effet, hein.
C'est ça.
Mais c'est vrai, quand vous faites des enquêtes, en général, les gens vous disent : Ah ben oui, quand je me mets à fumer, c'est dans un moment de détente.
En plus, souvent, avec les politiques de répression du tabac, ils sont souvent ensemble, c'est lié à un moment où ils doivent sortir.
Donc il y a tous des éléments contextuels qui donnent l'impression que le tabac relaxe. Mais c'est pas vrai. C'est le syndrome de sevrage qui est derrière ça, hein.
Quand vous regardez, quand vous en parlez avec des gens qui sont plus experts en pharmacodynamique, hein, sur l'effet du tabac, en fait, c'est très, très clair en fait, hein.
C'est essentiellement le syndrome du sevrage qui est soulagé parce que vous fumez, en fait.
Mh.
Je voudrais rapprocher ça d'une chose, puisqu'on a commencé à parler des adolescents.
Très longtemps, en fait, on a cru qu'on devait aborder la question de la prévention du tabac avec les adolescents en leur parlant des risques liés à la consommation de cigarettes.
En fait, il y a une chose que les adolescents sous-estiment, c'est à quelle rapidité on devient accro, on devient dépendant au tabac.
Et les adolescents, lorsqu'on leur parle de leur consommation de tabac, ils disent : C'est pas grave, je peux m'arrêter quand je veux.
Et puis de base, je pense savoir que chez les adolescents, il y a une plus grande difficulté à se projeter loin dans le futur et à mesurer les conséquences de leurs actes.
Oui, oui. Donc ça, c'est encore autre chose. Il faut reconnaître que si on parle de l'espérance de vie, ben oui, le tabac, c'est huit années d'espérance de vie en moins.
Et ces huit années, c'est pas tout de suite. C'est quand vous aurez au-delà de cinquante, soixante ans. Donc c'est un horizon de temps qui n'existe pas, en fait.
Voilà, pour les adolescents.
Pour les adolescents, non. Mais qui commence à exister lorsque vous commencez à avoir quarante, cinquante ans et que vous vous rendez compte que ces huit années risquent de venir assez vite.
Mais les adolescents, d'une manière générale, en fait, surestiment leur capacité à se sevrer dans un horizon de temps court.
Et ça, c'est une ignorance réelle, hein. Il y a eu quelques grosses études aux États-Unis où en fait, ils ont mis l'accent là-dessus.
Et c'est maintenant le point à la crosse. C'est surtout en fait rendre les adolescents conscients qu'en fait, ils perdent leur liberté, contrairement à votre campagne d'information de Marlboro.
C'est ça.
En fait, se mettre à fumer, c'est perdre sa liberté en fait. Tout l'inverse.
Créer une dépendance, oui. Vous-même, est-ce que vous avez déjà été fumeur ?
Non.
Jamais essayé ? Jamais consommé ?
Oui.
Non.
C'est pareil, moi non plus. Jamais, jamais touché de près ou de loin.
Ouais.
Du coup, on n'est absolument pas légitimes pour parler de cette prochaine question—
Qui est donc le fait que, concrètement, on sait qu'une cigarette, ça contient de l'arsenic, du goudron, du cyanure, de l'ammoniac, du benzène.
Donc c'est en principe, je présume, et vous présumez aussi que ça doit être absolument dégueulasse. Et c'est ce qu'on entend, hein, ce qu'on peut entendre, c'est que la première cigarette, d'après les témoignages que j'ai pu entendre—
Ouais.
Est assez dégueulasse.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire que la première cigarette est dégueulasse, mais que les suivantes, voilà, sont tolérables parce que l'addiction s'est déjà installée ?
Donc en fait, l'addiction, elle est là en trois semaines.
Hm hm.
Une cigarette par semaine, un peu plus rapidement chez les filles que chez les garçons. Mais c'est de l'ordre de quelques semaines.
Donc une cigarette par semaine et au bout de trois, quatre semaines, en fait, une ou un adolescent devient dépendant.
En fait, c'est dégueulasse, mais il faut bien se rendre compte que comme pas mal de comportements de santé ou de comportements à risque dans le domaine de la santé, ce sont des comportements qui sont appris avec les autres, hein.
Donc au début, les adolescents, par exemple, ils tirent, mais ils n'avalent pas.
Hm hm.
Oui, comme Bill Clinton.
C'est ça, voilà. Ils crapotent, comme ils disent. Et donc à ce moment-là, ils ont des remarques des autres.
On apprend en fait avec ses amis. On apprend à consommer, mais aussi, on apprend à accéder aux cigarettes, hein, puisque, comme mentionné dans vos questions, il y a toute une problématique d'accès à la cigarette.
Oui, d'ailleurs, oui, on peut y arriver maintenant. Comment est-ce que les jeunes de quinze, seize ans arrivent à accéder au tabac alors que— d'ailleurs, en Belgique, c'est à partir de seize ans, oui. Donc c'est—
Bah, c'est intéressant votre remarque parce que jusqu'il y a peu, c'était le cas.
Oui.
Et la Belgique était un outlier par rapport aux autres pays européens. On laissait les adolescents de seize ans acheter des cigarettes.
Ça a été revu il y a deux, trois ans.
Ah ok.
J'ai plus la date en tête.
J'étais pas-
C'était entre autres un des résultats de cette étude de Sydney. Et entre autres, pas seulement de cette étude, mais du gros travail fait par l'Alliance pour une génération sans tabac.
Ok. Donc c'est de votre faute ou grâce à vous que-
Et-
L'interdiction a monté un petit peu.
Et sans beaucoup d'autres acteurs comme la Fondation contre le cancer. Parce qu'aux Pays-Bas, en Angleterre, en France, c'était dix-huit ans.
Hm hm.
En Belgique, en fait, vous aviez des adolescents qui étaient dans l'école, en école secondaire-
Ouais, ouais.
Qui avaient seize ans ou dix-sept ans, qui achètent des cigarettes légalement et puis qui les ramènent à des plus jeunes dans l'école, en fait.
Oui, parfois même, qui fumaient dans la cour de récréation ou dans, voilà, dans les-
C'est ça.
Institutions qui sont peut-être un peu plus laxes que d'autres.
C'est ça. Ça, c'est un autre problème. C'est la question de la visibilité. Mais au niveau de l'accès,
en fait, on avait un gros souci en Belgique parce que comment est-ce qu'on pouvait interdire à des adolescents d'avoir des cigarettes si légalement, ils étaient en droit de les avoir ?
C'est ça.
Eh bien du coup, la Belgique a modifié sa réglementation pour augmenter l'âge d'achat à dix-huit ans quoi.
Hm hm.
Mais on l'a fait. Et ça, c'est symptomatique de pas mal de politiques de santé en Belgique. On l'a fait très tard-
Par rapport aux autres. On l'a fait un petit peu en rechignant.
Ouais.
Et de manière assez particulière, les partis qui sont en théorie, ou on s'attendrait en théorie qu'ils soient plus en faveur d'une réglementation comme cela, n'étaient pas en faveur de ça.
C'était lesquels pour...
Eh bien, le Parti socialiste, par exemple, je me rappelle de la conférence organisée par l'Alliance pour une génération sans tabac, n'était pas vraiment en faveur pour des politiques de répression dans ce domaine.
Parce que c'est vrai que vous retrouvez dans une population plus modeste une prévalence plus élevée de consommation de tabac.
Voilà. Et est-ce que-
Et donc c'était le gros paradoxe, c'était de dire : est-ce que je vais protéger les anciens fumeurs-
Hm hm.
Ou je protège ceux qui sont à risque de se mettre à fumer.
Il y aurait un lien alors avec l'électorat du PS qui est peut-être un peu plus ou très certainement même, voilà, moins favorisé que les autres et qui rejoindrait alors votre remarque de tout à l'heure-
C'est ça.
Comme quoi il y a plus de fumeurs chez les populations plus modestes.
Voilà. Ceci dit, on doit reconnaître qu'entre-temps, ils ont modifié leur point de vue là-dessus hein.
Hm hm.
Et donc finalement, ils ont soutenu-
Ouais.
La modification de la loi hein.
C'est plutôt une bonne chose. On parlait des effets nocifs du tabac. Des choses qu'on a pu lire et entendre dans certaines études dans les années nonante, en particulier, je pense à des études américaines.
On parlait de l'effet sur l'anxiété notamment, prétendu soulageant, pour le stress. Il y avait, voilà, ces études qui prétendaient que le tabac augmentait les capacités cognitives, augmentait la qualité de la mémoire et ce genre de choses.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité là-dessus ou est-ce que de nouveau, c'est simplement, on soulage une addiction et donc ça va mieux le temps de la cigarette ?
Ça, il faudrait poser la question à des experts en neurosciences.
Hm hm.
Mais ce que je peux vous dire, c'est que le tabac est entre autres un facteur de risque en matière de démence.
D'accord.
Ça, c'est-
Sur le long terme alors.
Sur le long terme.
Ouais.
C'est montré. Donc...
Parce que vraiment, on peut vraiment parler à des fumeurs qui vont prétendre qu'ils ont un sentiment de clarté, d'aisance, voilà, des capacités cognitives augmentées le temps d'une cigarette, selon eux.
Voilà, c'est des choses qu'on peut entendre.
Oui. Bon, on dit beaucoup de choses dans ce domaine. Ce qu'on sait, c'est qu'on perd neuf années— huit années, pardon, d'espérance de vie et que ça tue la moitié des consommateurs hein.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Et alors que ça a un effet non seulement sur un horizon de temps assez long, mais ça a un effet sur votre capacité respiratoire, sur votre sexualité, sur le teint de votre peau, sur vos cheveux.
Donc, l'un dans l'autre, est-ce qu'on ne devrait pas évaluer cette question-là sur l'impact du tabac, sur le fardeau de la maladie ?
Et le fardeau de la maladie, pour quinze pour cent, c'est le tabagisme hein. Il faut bien se rendre compte que quinze pour cent, je ne parle pas simplement des années perdues, mais des années perdues,
entre autres à cause d'une invalidité ou d'une incapacité.
Quinze pour cent de tout le fardeau de la maladie, c'est le tabac. C'est quand même énorme hein.
Et donc pour revenir à ce que vous disiez sur le fait qu'il y a une prévalence des populations plus modestes,
il y a effectivement, voilà, des statistiques qui sont disponibles en Belgique et qui montrent que les personnes qui ont un diplôme de l'enseignement secondaire inférieur, donc les trois premières années l'enseignement secondaire,
sont trois fois plus susceptibles de fumer quotidiennement que les personnes avec un diplôme de l'enseignement supérieur.
Pour la cigarette électronique, ce rapport, c'est plutôt deux, voilà, deux virgule quatre, quelque chose comme ça.
Qu'est-ce qui explique cette différence, voilà, que vous évoquiez déjà tout à l'heure ?
En fait, il y a plusieurs facteurs qui sont derrière là, mais principalement, c'est un effet de réseau. C'est-à-dire que les jeunes adolescents de milieux plus modestes, en fait, on les retrouve
beaucoup plus fréquemment exposés à la consommation de tabac parmi leurs amis.
Donc notre étude, SINNE, en fait, ce qu'elle a montré, c'est que au plus vous montez dans la
stratification sociale des jeunes et mesuré par plusieurs manières, le revenu des parents, le niveau de scolarité des parents ou aussi, de manière très intéressante,
le niveau de performance académique des, des adolescents eux-mêmes.
Au plus, vous allez vers le haut, si je puis dire, au moins, vous êtes exposé à des amis fumeurs
dans votre premier degré de séparation, c'est-à-dire vos amis directs, dans le deuxième degré de séparation, les amis de vos amis et même dans le troisième degré de séparation, les amis des amis de mes amis.
Également, au moins, vous êtes exposé au tabagisme à la maison.
Et donc en fait, si vous voulez, tout l'environnement social des adolescents d'origine sociale beaucoup plus modeste est beaucoup plus à risque et beaucoup plus composé soit d'amis qui sont fumeurs, soit de parents qui sont fumeurs.
Et donc on retrouve là le phénomène de la contagion sociale, mais qui n'est pas en fait distribué de la même manière chez ces différents adolescents.
Et alors un autre effet qui lui est plus institutionnel, c'est que vous avez deux, trois fois plus de tabagisme dans les écoles professionnelles et techniques par rapport aux écoles d'enseignement technique.
Et là, vous avez, si vous voulez, une cristallisation entre l'effet de réseau à titre individuel, mais l'effet institutionnel qui est lié au fait que certaines écoles,
en fait, ont des prévalences deux, trois fois plus élevées qu'une autre école qui se trouve dans la même ville.
L'étude SINNE, par exemple, était très intéressante parce qu'à Namur, on a pris sept écoles. Namur, c'est tout petit hein.
C'est la même législation hein, c'est la même communauté qui finance tout ça. Et en théorie, ça devrait être la même promotion de la santé.
Mais vous avez des différences de prévalence énormes au sein de la même ville, entre écoles, entre autres selon le statut socioéconomique de l'école.
Hein. Donc, en fait, c'est essentiellement des questions de réseau qui viennent être en partie modulées par ce qu'on peut appeler les politiques de régulation ou de contrôle de la consommation de tabac dans ces écoles.
Grosso modo, vous avez des écoles— vous aviez des écoles, on doit parler au passé puisque c'est une étude qui date déjà.
Vous aviez des écoles qui, grosso modo, fermaient les yeux sur la consommation du tabac dans l'école. Vous aviez des écoles avec des fumoirs.
Oui, tout à fait oui.
Dans l'école.
Notamment les internats et compagnie.
Voilà. Et alors parfois, c'étaient des fumoirs pour les profs. Et les profs disent : Oui, mais ça, c'est les élèves, c'est interdit, mais nous, on peut.
Avec toute la question de la crédibilité, finalement, d'une interdiction, si d'un côté, pour les profs, c'est autorisé et pour les élèves, ça ne l'est pas.
Et puis alors, vous aviez des lieux dans lesquels les écoles finalement autorisaient ou...
Fermaient les yeux.
Fermaient les yeux sur la consommation des adolescents. Il faut bien se rendre compte que dans l'étude SINNE, on a grosso modo entre un quart et un tiers des adolescents qui disaient voir fumer dans l'école.
Et les résultats dont je vous parle ici, c'est au niveau européen, puisque c'était une étude internationale. Je pense que c'était un petit peu plus élevé du côté namurois.
Donc énormément de visibilité du tabac dans les écoles et en particulier dans les écoles techniques, professionnelles. Et alors, le méga drame, c'est en fait, même
si vous ne pouvez pas fumer dans l'école, en fait, vous repoussiez la consommation de tabac à l'entrée d'école.
Oui, bien sûr.
Tout le monde s'y retrouve là. Et donc là, vous magnifiez la visibilité du tabac parce que bon, c'est interdit dans l'école, mais alors on repoussait la,
les fumeurs, que ce soit des enseignants et des étudiants, à fumer à l'entrée d'école, ce qui avait un peu l'effet inverse.
C'est de rendre le tabac plus visible.
Ce qui est le cas aussi dans les hôpitaux, par exemple.
Oui. Et ça, si vous regardez un petit peu à l'étranger hein, je reviens par exemple d'un séjour de six mois aux États-Unis, vous ne verrez jamais quelqu'un fumer devant l'entrée d'un bâtiment.
Jamais. C'est interdit. Vous devez aller ailleurs. Hein. C'est en général, vous avez des panneaux à l'entrée qui vous disent : Vous ne pouvez pas fumer à moins de dix mètres ou de quinze mètres ou de vingt mètres.
Même parfois sur des lieux de promenade publique, dans les parcs, vous ne pouvez pas
fumer dans les lieux publics. Et là, de ce côté-là, la Belgique a, à mon avis, encore pas mal de choses à faire pour réduire la visibilité de la consommation, entre autres à l'entrée des écoles.
Alors plein de questions qui se posent à ce moment-là. Déjà, voilà, vous évoquiez par exemple le fait que c'est magnifié dans les écoles techniques et professionnelles.
Vous donnez des chiffres pour concrétiser le fait qu'effectivement, plus les performances académiques sont élevées, moins il y a de fumeurs parmi les amis, la famille, deuxième degré, troisième degré, ainsi de suite.
Mais vous n'expliquez pas vraiment pourquoi.
Mais en fait, si vous voulez, les réseaux sont à l'origine des inégalités. La composition du réseau social est différente.
Et donc, si vous êtes un adolescent de douze ans, treize ans
et vous entrez dans une école professionnelle et que vous êtes exposé à un groupe d'amis où la prévalence est deux, trois fois plus élevée qu'un autre groupe d'amis dans une autre école où la prévalence est beaucoup plus faible,
tout simplement, votre propension d'initier le tabac est beaucoup plus élevée.
Et donc c'est très récursif, en fait.
Oui, bien sûr.
Le fait que le tabac soit beaucoup plus prévalent dans les classes sociales moins privilégiées, dans les écoles techniques et professionnelles, est causé par le fait que le tabac est plus prévalent dans les écoles techniques et professionnelles.
Est causé par le fait que les réseaux-
Oui.
De relations sociales de ces adolescents, soit dans les écoles professionnelles les plus prévalentes, soit dans les autres écoles, qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle de l'homophilie dans les relations sociales.
Donc ça, c'est le deuxième paramètre de l'explication des réseaux.
Mhmm.
Si vous voulez, nos relations sociales, elles sont homophiles.
On est attiré par les gens qui nous ressemblent.
Oui, mais on est attiré par les gens qui nous ressemblent, entre autres sur la classe sociale.
Oui oui.
Hein.
C'est ça.
Dans une école, laissons tomber momentanément des écoles type techniques et professionnelles. En fait, on sait que les adolescents ont une tendance plus élevée
à frayer, à développer des relations et à les maintenir avec d'autres adolescents qui sont similaires à eux.
Similaires à eux sur deux caractéristiques. On va laisser tomber tout ce qui est plutôt socio-démo hein, âge et genre, puisque c'est moins l'objet ici, mais en particulier, la performance scolaire.
Donc un adolescent a tendance à frayer avec d'autres adolescents qui sont de la même performance scolaire et d'autre part, de la même classe sociale.
Hein. Et donc, si vous voulez, vous avez ce même mécanisme que vous appelez récursif, mais qui fait qu'en fait, des adolescents de milieux sociaux plus modestes vont être exposés de manière plus importante au tabagisme
via les amis avec lesquels ils sont.
Et également parce que on a un constat assez régulier, c'est que des élèves qui sont en général en situation d'échec scolaire ou avec une performance scolaire plus faible,
hein, sont deux à trois fois plus à risque d'être soit des fumeurs réguliers, soit d'avoir initié.
D'accord.
Donc, si vous voulez, vous avez une sorte de terreau social, là, de création des inégalités sociales de tabagisme qui vont perdurer après à l'âge adulte.
Mais ce que vous dites sur les élèves moins performants à l'école, c'est vrai, y compris, voilà, dans les écoles, entre guillemets, plus traditionnelles, plus tradi-
Oui.
Plus BCBG, etc.
Et c'est même vrai, si vous voulez, dans des pays où il y a des politiques de contrôle et de prévention du tabac beaucoup plus avancées, comme la Finlande, qui faisait partie de l'étude SINNE.
Donc ce même gradient réussite scolaire élevée, tabagisme faible, on le retrouve dans tous les pays.
D'accord, et comment ça se fait ?
Ah, c'est lié à deux choses. C'est d'abord, c'est que des élèves qui en général ont des taux de réussite plus faibles, sont en général des élèves plus âgés.
Ok.
Des élèves plus âgés-
En particulier en Belgique, on fait beaucoup de redoublements.
Oui, donc il y a la question du redoublement.
Mais ces élèves-là, si vous voulez, sont des élèves qui ont une trajectoire, une exposition, ou simplement la probabilité, puisqu'ils sont un peu plus âgés,
d'avoir été exposés au tabac plus élevé que des élèves qui ont une réussite scolaire plus favorable.
Et deux, c'est que souvent, ce sont des élèves qui viennent de milieux sociaux plus modestes, hein. Et donc qui amènent, si vous voulez, avec eux-
D'accord, oui.
Leur environnement social et y compris leur environnement lié au tabac.
D'accord, oui, ok.
Si vous voulez, l'homophilie des réseaux sociaux a cet effet qui consiste à magnifier une petite différence dans une inégalité et qui, du fait de ce réseau social-là, en fait, va être amplifiée au sein de l'école-
Mhmm.
Mais aussi entre écoles.
D'accord, oui. Donc vraiment, la faible performance scolaire et le tabagisme vont avoir une cause commune qui donc serait, voilà, l'environnement social plus modeste et donc, vous disiez, l'homophilie-
Homophilie.
Relationnelle, oui, qui fait que tout ça va, entre guillemets, tourbillonner, entre guillemets, se renforcer.
C'est ça. Ce sont des mécanismes dynamiques qu'on retrouve par exemple dans plein de choses. Si en janvier ou en février, vous voulez faire du dry January ou dry February-
Mhmm.
Et voulez ne pas consommer d'alcool à la maison, ben, c'est compliqué si votre conjoint ne vous suit pas.
C'est ça.
C'est compliqué si vos amis ne vous suivent pas. Donc, en fait, si vous voulez, ces relations sociales peuvent être des freins ou, à l'inverse, peuvent potentialiser des comportements de santé.
Est-ce que le tabac peut aussi être un obstacle dans cette mécanique que vous disiez d'homophilie ? Je vais y arriver.
Est-ce que, par exemple, un groupe de personnes peut accueillir plus difficilement un nouvel individu au sein de son groupe parce que cette personne fume ou ne fume pas ?
Vous avez tout à fait raison. La relation va aussi dans l'autre sens.
Oui.
Quand on regarde les choses de manière dynamique, en fait, on remarque d'ailleurs que les adolescents choisissent également leurs amis ou les déchoisissent, hein, en fonction du statut tabagique, hein.
Parce que le tabac est devenu, si vous voulez, une sorte de marqueur de classe sociale. Il faut bien se rendre compte de ça, hein.
Les comportements de santé, le tabagisme, au départ, c'était surtout une innovation qui nous venait des classes sociales plus favorisées, hein,
qui ont été les premières à fumer et puis qui maintenant se sont très largement retirées de la consommation de tabac.
Et donc, paradoxalement, le tabac, la consommation de tabac est devenue un marqueur de classe.
Mh.
Si on regarde les statistiques, encore une fois, sur les vingt-cinq, trente dernières années, on remarque concrètement que la prévalence des fumeurs quotidiens est passée d'environ 30 % en nonante-sept
à aujourd'hui quelque chose qui ressemble plutôt à du 19 %.
Et chez les jeunes, on est même passé de vingt-cinq à 11 %.
Ouais.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui explique cette diminution ?
Ouais. En fait, c'est principalement le résultat des politiques économiques.
L'augmentation du-
On sait que la meilleure politique de prévention du tabac, ce sont les taxes, hein.
Ok.
Le prix. Donc les citoyens, les consommateurs sont des gens plutôt rationnels. Donc, on sait que les taxes sur le tabac constituent des politiques particulièrement efficaces.
Mais comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure, alors, c'est paradoxal puisque-
Ouais.
Logiquement, les classes sociales plus modestes-
Voilà.
Devraient être les premières impactées par ce changement-là, mais on remarque que finalement non. Donc c'est-
Mais donc en fait, ces politiques fonctionnent très bien au niveau populationnel, mais ça ne veut pas dire que toutes les couches de la population y répondent de la même manière.
On sait néanmoins que ces taxes jouent également sur la consommation de tabac de catégories sociales plus modestes.
Mais si vous voulez, vous avez plein d'effets comme ceux dont je viens de parler qui peuvent faire que, ben, les taxes vont être plus efficaces dans certains groupes que d'autres.
Et puis l'initiation, elle peut constituer un coût finalement relativement faible au départ.
Mhmm.
Et vous êtes confronté au coût, à terme, au fur et à mesure de votre cycle de vie. Donc, si vous voulez, ces politiques-là sont efficaces à un niveau populationnel, mais ne sont pas parvenues à réduire les inégalités.
En matière de tabagisme. Entre autres pour ces effets de réseau dont je vous parle.
Donc les effets de réseau seraient plus forts que la volonté de gérer son budget et de s'en sortir au niveau des fins de mois.
Si on constate que le coût du morceau de tabac, le fait d'être fumeur quotidien coûte cher, très cher.
Ouais.
Il devrait y avoir logiquement une motivation importante pour arrêter de fumer quand on a en particulier des fins de mois difficiles.
Mais vous avez l'air de dire que les effets de réseau sont plus forts que ce besoin de gérer ces fins de mois ?
Les effets de réseau, en fait, expliquent l'initiation différentielle entre les couches sociales.
L'initiation. Ah oui, c'est ça, oui.
Les effets de réseau, en fait, vont faire que des groupes sociaux vont être plus rapidement, plus intensément exposés à la consommation de tabac et donc au risque d'initiation.
D'accord.
Où là, à ce moment-là, l'enjeu économique est faible. L'enjeu économique, il devient beaucoup plus important au bout d'une trajectoire de tabagisme.
Mais à ce moment-là, c'est autre chose qui joue.
C'est ça.
C'est la question de la dépendance, en fait. Donc, si vous voulez, les effets de réseau, en fait, viennent moduler la manière dont ces politiques macroéconomiques affectent la consommation de tabac.
On doit y ajouter les milieux de vie aussi dans lesquels évoluent ces adolescents. Une politique, en fait, elle peut être implémentée de manière assez différente d'un milieu à l'autre.
Et ça, c'est peut-être le deuxième facteur sur lequel on peut mettre l'accent, c'est l'application de la réglementation sur le tabac.
Et dans l'étude Sydney, ce qu'on a montré, en fait, c'est que grosso modo, les écoles étaient relativement tièdes à appliquer la réglementation sur le tabac.
Grosso modo, dans toutes les écoles européennes, hein, les cinquante écoles qu'on a étudiées en 2013. Et puis, on en a eu trente-huit qui ont été réinterrogées plus tard sur les cinq ans.
D'abord, ce qu'on a constaté, c'est que le score était environ de six sur dix.
Score de ?
De respect de la réglementation.
D'accord. Donc précisément à Namur, là où vous avez...
C'était un petit peu plus faible à Namur et un petit peu plus élevé dans d'autres pays.
D'accord.
Mais en moyenne, dans l'ensemble des écoles européennes, ça tournait aux alentours de six sur dix. Et que ce qui était application des sanctions, qu'on appelle en anglais enforcement, c'est-à-dire, il y a une règle,
mais on la fait respecter, hein.
Là, on tombait à quatre sur dix. Donc, en fait, il y a des règles, mais elles sont peu appliquées et surtout, en fait, il n'y a aucune sanction.
On a également constaté que c'était extrêmement hétérogène d'une école à l'autre. Au sein de la même ville, certaines écoles respectaient strictement la réglementation et sanctionnaient les comportements qui ne respectaient pas les règles.
D'autres écoles ne les mettaient pas du tout en œuvre.
Mh.
Et alors, la troisième chose qu'on observait, c'est qu'entre 2013 et 2016, en fait, il n'y a quasiment pas eu d'évolution.
Donc les écoles, en fait, s'investissent très très peu dans cette question-là.
Et pourquoi ?
Il y a plusieurs raisons, mais la principale, c'est que d'une part, les écoles considèrent que ce n'est pas leur job.
Les écoles considèrent que tout ce qui est prévention de la santé, respect de la réglementation en matière de tabac, ce n'est pas vraiment une priorité pour elles.
Ok. Et ça, on le remarque partout en Europe, de manière à peu près constante ?
Non, non. Vous aviez des pays où l'enjeu était pris bien plus au sérieux. Un très bon exemple de ce côté-là, c'était la Finlande.
Toujours, toujours la Finlande, la Suède.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Toujours, ouais.
Entre autres, ils ont une véritable politique, je pense, de promotion de la santé dans les écoles, hein. On en est loin de notre côté...
Les PSE, par exemple, ça reste du communautaire, mais ils sont débordés par leur bilan de santé, donc ils font-
PSE qui signifie donc ?
Promotion de la santé à l'école.
D'accord.
On a constaté qu'il y avait peu d'évolution.
Et avec ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure, ce gros paradoxe, c'est que
pour faire respecter la réglementation sur l'interdiction de fumer dans les écoles, eh bien, on repousse le comportement à la barrière, à l'entrée, où sa visibilité est amplifiée, en fait.
Il y a aussi, je pense, une résistance à aller dire à un fumeur, aussi jeune soit-il, qu'il ne peut pas fumer, qu'il doit aller fumer ailleurs, qu'il doit, voilà, qu'il doit s'asseoir.
Parce qu'il y a vraiment très fort cet argument de la liberté, de dire : oui, mais bon voilà, il est fumeur, c'est son droit, bon, c'est pas terrible, mais livre à lui.
Exact.
Quel est votre sentiment par rapport à ça ?
En fait, c'est très intéressant, votre remarque. C'est d'application pour le tabac, mais c'est aussi d'application, par exemple, pour la consommation d'alcool.
En Belgique, on considère toujours que c'est une question de comportement individuel, de responsabilité individuelle.
Mh.
Et tant qu'on n'a pas bougé sur cette perspective-là, on n'avancera pas. En fait, la consommation de tabac, ce n'est pas une responsabilité individuelle, hein, elle est collective.
C'est une question du déterminisme, de l'environnement qui produit des addictions au tabac.
D'abord ça, dans l'initiation, ça, c'est bien montré, mais surtout quand vous fumez, en fait, ben d'abord, vous exposez les autres autour de vous.
Tabagisme passif, oui.
Oui, tabagisme passif. Et surtout, en fait, ce comportement, il est transmis à d'autres par apprentissage, par imitation, par accès, par opportunité.
Oui.
Donc, ce qui est vrai pour le tabac est vrai aussi pour d'autres choses comme la consommation d'alcool. Il y a une sorte de refus de voir cela comme un enjeu collectif, en fait. C'est collectif.
Mh.
C'est un comportement social. Et la grande majorité, d'ailleurs, des comportements de santé sont des comportements sociaux.
Et donc, tant qu'on est avec une idéologie de la responsabilité individuelle, on ne bougera pas. L'autre enjeu, c'est les enseignants, hein.
Les enseignants considèrent que cette législation a été conçue pour les élèves.
Ils ne se sentent pas concernés. Mais comment voulez-vous être crédible pour appliquer une réglementation,
dans une école si les élèves savent que, par ailleurs, finalement, on ferme les yeux sur la consommation des enseignants dans l'école ?
Oui, oui, oui.
En fait, la politique doit considérer qu'une école est un lieu où on ne fume pas à tout moment, pour tout le monde, partout.
Les salles fumeurs pour les professeurs, ça existe toujours aujourd'hui ?
Alors, c'est une très bonne question. On avait fait une petite étude qualitative avec des étudiants du master en santé publique.
Mais bon, c'est une étude qui date déjà, hein, elle a été publiée dans l'Éducation Santé. On a montré qu'il y avait pas mal de tolérance de ce côté-là.
J'aurais envie de poser la question à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles : où en est l'évaluation de l'interdiction de 2006, en fait, hein, puisque grosso modo, c'est depuis 2006.
Où en est l'évaluation du-
Effectivement, moi, j'étais à l'école secondaire en 2006 et c'était absolument— elle était toujours là, la salle fumeurs.
Oui. Donc la réglementation a été prise à ce moment-là. Alors très longtemps, il y a eu un conflit entre est-ce que c'est la législation sur le travail qui s'applique ou c'est la législation sur les écoles.
Mais grosso modo, l'administration de l'enseignement laisse au pouvoir organisateur le soin de régler ça par le, comment, le règlement d'ordre intérieur.
Oui. Et est-ce qu'on peut penser que le fait de voir des professeurs fumer a un impact ? Puisque, voilà, on disait que c'est une dynamique de réseautage, d'imitation, de ces cercles sociaux de premier degré ou deuxième degré.
Hum, est-ce que le fait de voir un professeur fumer, ça va avoir une influence positive sur le fait de vouloir commencer à fumer ou est-ce que...
Oui, la réponse est oui. Mais en tout cas, ça a une influence sur finalement la force de la règle.
Oui, d'accord.
Puisque si vous avez à l'entrée un éducateur, un professeur, voire un directeur qui fume, quelle est sa crédibilité après pour vous sanctionner si jamais vous fumez ?
Oui. Ça, quand vous dites ça, ça me fait penser aux images qu'on avait vues de la législation. Je pense que c'était en Grèce ou en Albanie ou dans les Balkans, d'un parlement où le ministre de la Santé appliquait une règle sur le
fait qu'on ne pouvait plus fumer au parlement.
Et il faisait ça avec une cigarette en main. Effectivement, la notion d'hypocrisie est toujours un peu, effectivement...
On n'est pas crédible, en fait. On n'est pas crédible. Donc, pour vous donner un exemple assez intéressant, aux États-Unis, c'est 5 % des adolescents qui fument.
Et quelle est la différence alors ?
Ah ben ils sont beaucoup plus stricts au niveau des règles.
D'accord.
En fait, moi, j'ai un peu parfois l'impression que les règles ici, en fait, elles perdent en puissance parce que tout simplement, on ne les met pas en application.
Et souvent, avec un récit qui dit : mais on ne va pas rajouter du malheur au malheur, hein, en sanctionnant des élèves qui fument.
Mais ça, c'est ignorer qu'en fait, les comportements sont en grande partie liés à des attentes sociales, hein. Et d'autre part, que les comportements sont, entre autres, appris à travers les autres.
Et donc, finalement, vous ne sanctionnez pas un élève fumeur, mais vous ne voyez pas l'absence de protection que vous laissez de côté par rapport à un élève qui pourrait se mettre à fumer et qui ne fume pas.
Il y a une confusion totale au niveau des enjeux dans ce domaine.
Vous évoquiez donc à plusieurs reprises l'étude CINÉ qui a été menée donc entre 2013 et 2018. Vous avez évoqué une série de chiffres, une série d'outcomes de cette étude.
D'autres aspects à ajouter qu'on n'a pas encore pu explorer ?
Ben je pense que la question du tabac est parfois considérée comme un vieux problème. On sait en santé publique que les responsables politiques, ils s'intéressent aux nouveaux problèmes.
Hein, les anciens problèmes, ben, en général, comme ils durent, on,
en général, on s'en désintéresse très très vite. Je pense que ça touche du doigt la nécessité de développer une véritable politique de promotion de la santé dans les écoles.
Hein. Le tabac en est certainement une dimension pertinente dans pas mal d'écoles, peut-être plus dans certaines écoles que dans d'autres, hein.
Quand j'en parle, par exemple, avec mes collègues néerlandophones, ils me regardent en me disant : Mais c'est déjà plus un problème en Flandre.
Donc sans doute que différentes régions
sont confrontées différemment à ce problème-là. Mais ce dont on a besoin, que ce soit à Bruxelles, en Wallonie, mais aussi même en Flandre, c'est une véritable politique de promotion de la santé dans les écoles qui requiert sans doute,
à mon avis, de revoir un petit peu la manière dont les compétences sont mises en œuvre dans ce domaine.
Puisque rappelez-vous, si je peux me permettre, les assuétudes, c'est des régions, mais la promotion de la santé, c'est la communauté.
Et donc, moi, je pose la question : OK, mais qui s'occupe de la promotion de la santé dans les écoles qui concerne les assuétudes en fait ?
C'est la fameuse lasagne institutionnelle belge qui revient régulièrement dans ce podcast sur le... C'est la faute à qui ? Qui doit gérer ça ?
Oui, c'est ça. Ben c'est-à-dire que, bon voilà, la lasagne, elle est là et c'est pas à moi de dire qui doit faire quoi.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y a ici sans doute un exemple d'une compétence qui est à l'intersection de plusieurs acteurs et qui est laissée un petit peu comme un parent pauvre.
Or, la santé des adolescents, c'est la santé de la population à l'avenir en fait hein. Nos comportements de santé, ils sont appris grosso modo à l'école, à travers les pairs.
Alors c'est vrai pour le tabac, mais c'est vrai aussi pour le cannabis, c'est vrai pour la consommation d'alcool, c'est vrai pour l'activité physique, c'est vrai pour plein de choses.
Oui, oui. Je vous posais la question de savoir qu'est-ce qui avait amené le pourcentage de fumeurs quotidiens à baisser aussi fort ces trente dernières années.
Donc, vous m'avez répondu, le prix du tabac est vraiment le facteur numéro un.
Les questions de politique de répression dans les restaurants, dans les avions, dans certains lieux publics, est-ce que ça a eu un effet aussi ?
Oui, ben ça participe de ce qu'on appelle la dénormalisation d'un comportement. Si vous voulez, le prix, il vient créer un incitant, un désincitant, pardon, économique à ne pas continuer à fumer ou éventuellement pas s'y mettre à fumer.
Mais tant que vous n'avez pas une bonne politique de dénormalisation du comportement, ben vous allez maintenir le comportement ou alors il va se diffuser dans certains groupes plutôt que d'autres.
Donc toute la dénormalisation, que ce soit dans l'Horeca, dans les lieux publics ou dans les écoles, en fait, est un facteur majeur dans la promotion de la santé et dans la prévention du tabac aussi.
OK. Et donc, ouais, c'est une combinaison entre cette augmentation du prix du paquet et dénormalisation, comme vous dites, qui fait que ça a pu fonctionner.
La question des campagnes d'information et le packaging notamment, qu'on voit depuis, je crois, une dizaine d'années environ-
Ouais.
Avec des, voilà, des photos qui font peur de poumons et de globes oculaires très effrayants sur le paquet de cigarettes, la marque qui est vraiment mise en tout petit.
Est-ce que ça a un effet aussi ?
Je suis pas sûr que ce sont des politiques qui sont très efficaces à titre spécifique. En fait, si vous voulez, on a tendance à revoir ses croyances en fonction de son comportement.
Mh.
Donc si vous fumez, en fait, vos croyances sur le tabac vont changer.
On va voir un billet et on va se dire-
Oui, c'est, c'est-
Ils exagèrent. Ils exagèrent. Ça ne peut pas être aussi vrai que ça.
Oui, ou alors vous allez vous raccrocher à d'autres sources d'information, hein, qui peuvent venir des cigarettiers ou qui peuvent venir même de statistiques, mais que vous interprétez mal.
Quand je vous dis que le tabac tue un fumeur sur deux, ben vous pourriez le prendre en sens inverse, en fait, hein. Vous pourriez dire : mais il y a un fumeur sur deux qui ne décède pas du tabac.
Donc, si vous voulez, on va chercher l'information en général qui vient confirmer nos croyances.
Mh, mh. OK.
Et donc, ben si vous avez des photos un peu gênantes sur votre paquet, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce que ça vient vraiment modifier vos croyances ?
Mh. Est-ce qu'il y a pas même une mécanique, là, je spécule complètement, mais de se dire on essaye très fort de m'encourager à arrêter et moi, j'ai une certaine indépendance.
Je ne suis pas un mouton, je ne fais pas exactement ce qu'on me dit. Je reste un fumeur indépendant, fort, maître de ma destinée-
Ouais.
Comme dirait Marlboro.
Et je fais ce que j'ai envie. Est-ce qu'il y a pas carrément une attitude un peu contrarienne qui arrive ?
Bon, les êtres humains, en fait, ils ont comme caractéristique, c'est qu'ils racontent des histoires, on appelle ça en anglais des narratives-
Mh.
Hein, qui ont deux vocations en fait. La première, en fait, c'est protéger son identité, qui on est pour les autres.
Donc si je fume, en fait, dans un environnement extrêmement dénormalisé par rapport au tabac ou même dans un groupe social où on fume très très peu, j'ai besoin d'une histoire pour protéger mon identité sociale, en fait.
Et ces histoires, en fait, comme celles que vous venez de nous donner, des récits, en fait, sont des récits qui essentiellement ont pour effet de protéger son identité sociale.
Et la deuxième caractéristique, c'est qu'on a besoin d'histoires cohérentes. Donc on crée des histoires qui ont un sens.
Mais ce sens, en fait, c'est juste lié au récit, en fait. C'est pas un sens qui va nécessairement puiser dans la science.
Mh.
En fait.
Hein. Mais c'est un récit qui permet de protéger son identité aux yeux des autres et aux yeux de soi-même, en fait. Hein.
C'est ça.
Ça, il faut en être bien conscient. Ça veut pas dire qu'il faut négliger ces récits. Hein.
Au contraire, il faut peut-être y être attentif, mais il faut y être attentif pour voir quel est le besoin qui est derrière, hein, et qui est souvent un besoin d'appartenir,
hein, ou qui peut être implicitement, en fait, une reconnaissance que c'est extrêmement difficile de s'arrêter.
Mh.
Vous n'êtes pas fumeur, je ne le suis pas, mais je sais par ailleurs que s'arrêter de fumer est extrêmement compliqué.
Dix, vingt ans après, la dépendance est toujours là et le nombre de tentatives d'arrêt du tabac est phénoménal chez les fumeurs avant qu'ils la réussissent, hein.
C'est Mark Twain qui disait : « Arrêter de fumer, rien de plus facile. Je l'ai déjà fait mille fois ».
Ouais, c'est ça. Voilà. Mais les rechutes, c'est ce qu'il y a de plus fréquent. Donc ce qui veut dire que, j'imagine que pour un fumeur, ça doit pas être facile d'être face à ces échecs successifs.
Mh.
Mais c'est pas leur faute, en fait, c'est lié à la substance, c'est lié à l'addiction.
Bien sûr. Mais donc on peut parler alors des outils qui sont à leur disposition pour arrêter de fumer.
Aujourd'hui, moi, j'ai en tête les trucs type les patchs de nicotine, les-- on va parler après de la cigarette électronique.
Mais qu'est-ce qui fonctionne aujourd'hui pour arrêter de fumer ? Est-ce qu'on va voir son tabacologue ? Est-ce qu'on se colle une dizaine de patchs nicotine ?
Je crois qu'en fait, les évidences scientifiques vont vers une combinaison de facteurs-
Mh.
Des réponses pharmacologiques, mais aussi des approches plutôt psy-
Des approches liées aux approches comportementales, puisque la dépendance au tabac a plusieurs composantes. Elle a certainement une composante physique, mais elle a aussi une composante psychologique, hein.
Donc ça veut dire aussi trouver des environnements où on est moins tenté de fumer.
Se créer un réseau qui nous a fait...
Voilà. Et parfois aussi modifier son réseau social, hein.
C'est ça, oui.
Donc si j'ai des potes qui sont fumeurs et que je veux m'arrêter de fumer, ben peut-être que je dois réfléchir à ça.
Une très belle étude américaine sur la communauté de Framingham, aux États-Unis, a montré qu'au fil du temps, en fait, les fumeurs devenaient de plus en plus périphériques dans les réseaux sociaux.
Donc, si vous voulez, l'arrêt du tabac est associé avec aussi un changement dans la composition de votre réseau social.
On perd ses amis fumeurs quand on arrête.
Ah ben, c'est-à-dire que c'est certainement un facteur qui n'aide pas si vous gardez vos amis fumeurs.
Mh.
Ce qui explique aussi, par exemple, que c'est plus facile de réussir un sevrage tabagique si les deux partenaires ensemble, dans le cas où ils soient tous les deux fumeurs, ensemble, décident de s'arrêter.
Mh, mh.
Hein. Donc, de la même manière que c'est un comportement social à l'initiation, c'est sans doute aussi un comportement social lors du sevrage, hein.
Et donc ça demande pas que des solutions de type pharmacologique, hein, avec des aides qui vous permettent de vous aider dans ce domaine, mais également des approches plus de psychologie comportementale cognitive.
Mh. On m'a également parlé d'hypnose ou ce genre de choses-là. C'est des choses dont vous entendez parler aussi ?
Oui, bon, dans ce domaine, il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses, hein. L'acupuncture aussi.
Ouais, ouais.
Voilà, il faut aller vers ce qui marche, hein. Et ça, c'est peut-être important, c'est d'aller vers une culture des évidences, comme-
Mh.
Comme on dit en anglais, c'est-à-dire finalement de privilégier et de favoriser le remboursement des approches qui ont montré leurs preuves, leur efficacité.
Donc combiner plusieurs approches, s'extraire peut-être des réseaux sociaux qui nous ont peut-être conditionnés à fumer au quotidien.
Peut-être aussi, si on est habitué à fumer en mangeant ou ce genre de choses, peut-être essayer de changer son approche et de-
Oui. En médecine générale, ils ont développé une approche des cinq A, hein, comme ça. La première chose, c'est d'abord reconnaître le problème hein.
Par exemple, quand un médecin généraliste pose la question à son patient. Il sait être fumeur parce qu'en général, les signaux sont là.
Lui conseiller, hein, le deuxième A, advise. Donc le premier A, c'est to ask, to advise. Donc lui conseiller de s'arrêter de fumer.
Et on sait par exemple qu'en médecine générale, il y a des médecins généralistes qui sont réticents à s'engager là-dedans parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie de bagarre avec,
avec leurs patients, parce qu'ils savent, comme vous l'avez bien dit, que la rechute est plutôt la règle générale.
Et donc il faut soutenir les médecins généralistes dans cette œuvre difficile du sevrage.
Ce que je remarque souvent quand les médecins-- ce qui est typique hein, les médecins me demandent : Est-ce que vous êtes fumeur ?
Il y a toujours ce moment où ils me regardent droit dans les yeux parce qu'ils veulent vérifier. En tout cas, c'est mon sentiment, c'est mon impression.
Ils veulent essayer de vérifier, de déceler peut-être des signaux de est-ce que je suis en train de mentir quoi. Donc, ils me regardent droit dans les yeux pour s'en assurer.
En fait, la difficulté du tabagisme, c'est que c'est devenu un enjeu moral maintenant.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Hein. Et donc dès que c'est un enjeu moral, c'est un enjeu délicat dans les soins de santé, puisqu'en théorie, les soignants ne sont pas là pour vous juger.
En théorie, oui.
En théorie. Mais on sait par ailleurs que certains comportements de santé maintenant sont de plus en plus dénormalisés, donc dévalorisés, donc à risque de stigmatisation.
Ce qui, à mon avis, ne facilite pas le métier des médecins généralistes. Mais je pense que ce secteur-là est sans doute le secteur qu'il faudrait aider.
En tout cas pour la question que vous posez sur le sevrage, sans doute que le problème passe plutôt par une stratégie de ce qu'on appelle une génération sans tabac.
Faire en sorte que d'abord les enfants, les adolescents ne s'y mettent pas. Mais ça n'enlève pas la pertinence d'une stratégie pour le sevrage, hein. Certainement.
On va reparler de cette notion de génération sans tabac. Parlons maintenant donc de la fameuse cigarette électronique.
Est-ce que ça concerne les mêmes strates sociales ? Est-ce que ce sont les mêmes personnes qui, pour ainsi dire, les mêmes personnes qui fument cigarette électronique et des cigarettes normales ?
Est-ce que ce sont des personnes différentes ? Est-ce que ça peut être considéré comme un accessoire qui peut aider à arrêter de fumer ou est-ce que pas du tout ?
Est-ce que c'est tout aussi nocif ? Est-ce que c'est beaucoup moins nocif ? Quelles sont les différences ?
Là, je dois être prudent parce que ce n'est pas un sujet que je connais très très bien.
D'accord.
La question du vapotage, il y a des aspects que je connais mieux les uns que les autres. Le vapotage a été abordé dans l'étude Ciné dans la deuxième vague et de fait, c'était relativement fréquent, y compris chez les fumeurs.
Donc une des choses intéressantes, c'est que souvent les fumeurs combinent vapotage et cigarettes hein. Longtemps, la théorie a été de dire le vapotage est une manière de s'arrêter de fumer.
Mais on voit que chez un certain nombre d'adolescents maintenant, le vapotage devient l'entrée vers le-- la porte d'entrée vers le tabagisme.
Donc en fait, il faut être extrêmement prudent à considérer le vapotage comme une sorte de...
Porte de sortie.
De porte de sortie. Ça l'est sans doute hein, pour un certain nombre de fumeurs très dépendants, mais le risque, c'est que ça devienne porte d'entrée du tabagisme chez des adolescents.
Alors aussi, comme beaucoup d'innovations en général, le vapotage arrive d'abord par les personnes les plus centrales, les plus populaires, donc les fumeurs, puisque dans les écoles, souvent,
les fumeurs sont des gens qui sont, d'un point de vue structural, dans le réseau, ils sont plus centraux.
Hein. Donc ils ont une plus grande capacité à diffuser leur comportement vers les autres que s'ils étaient plutôt périphériques.
Et le vapotage est certainement une innovation qui circule par les réseaux sociaux. Hein, à nouveau. Quand je dis, excusez-moi, quand je dis réseaux sociaux, je ne veux pas du tout parler des réseaux
virtuels, mais je parle des réseaux de contacts sociaux.
On l'avait bien compris. On l'avait bien compris. Et ne serait-ce qu'au niveau, voilà, de pulmonaire, est-ce que c'est dangereux ?
Est-ce que c'est moins dangereux ? Vous avez des connaissances à ce niveau-là ?
Ben en fait, ça dépend aussi de la composition puisqu'on avait de la e-cigarette avec ou sans arôme. Est-ce qu'il y a de la nicotine ou pas ?
Vous avez des e-cigarettes où il n'y a pas de nicotine ou c'est juste des arômes. Et en fait, en général, les adolescents ne savent pas toujours très bien ce qu'il y a dedans. Hein.
Si c'est avec de la nicotine, ben vous créez finalement cette même dépendance
que vous avez avec la cigarette, si ce n'est que vous n'avez pas les effets négatifs liés au goudron et aux autres métaux lourds que vous avez dans la cigarette.
Donc, on pourrait dire que le vapotage peut-être a des effets un peu moins nocifs sur tout ce qui est fonction respiratoire, mais crée la même dépendance finalement à travers la nicotine quoi.
Question qui n'est peut-être pas directement liée au tabagisme, mais qui est quand même assez connexe. On parle de légalisation du cannabis.
Est-ce que ce serait pour vous quelque chose de positif ou de négatif en termes de santé publique ? Parce que c'est une question qui est compliquée.
Oui. En fait, cela revient à un grand débat en amont qui est sur la prohibition, la réduction des risques et la décriminalisation des comportements à risque.
C'est-à-dire que le problème, c'est la prohibition. La prohibition crée le problème.
Et que la prohibition ne marche pas.
Et que la prohibition ne marche pas. Et ça a amené à des modifications importantes de politiques en matière de drogue, par exemple au Portugal hein, où ils ont décriminalisé
la consommation de drogue en comparaison avec d'autres pays plutôt nordiques où on les a maintenues.
C'est pas mon domaine d'expertise si la question est d'un point de vue efficacité de santé publique. Ce que je peux dire, c'est que si je me place d'un point de vue plus sociologique maintenant.
En fait, les comportements sont pas des décisions individuelles. D'ailleurs, le terme comportement est peut-être un peu mal choisi, ce sont des pratiques.
Mmm-hmm.
Et ces pratiques, elles sont apprises au côté, acquises, soutenues par les autres.
Encore une fois, du déterminisme social-
Ben, le terme déterminisme va peut-être un peu loin, mais en tout cas, ne pas oublier qu'une bonne partie de ces pratiques sont acquises à travers les relations sociales.
Un conditionnement, si ce n'est pas un déterminisme.
C'est ça. Une influence en tout cas sociale. Et puis qui se retourne dans l'autre sens, c'est-à-dire une fois que vous avez le comportement ou la pratique, vous modifiez votre réseau social, entre autres, pour-
Mmm-hmm.
Cadrer avec cette pratique, hein. Donc il y a des effets dynamiques là-derrière aussi. Et je pense que la prohibition, pour revenir à votre question,
peut avoir pour effet de contribuer à une dénormalisation d'un comportement qui, d'un point de vue santé publique, n'est peut-être pas nécessairement favorable.
Mmm-hmm, mmm-hmm.
On connaît les risques liés au cannabis, hein. Et il y a toujours cette question sur le lien entre cannabis et incidences d'épisodes, par exemple, de schizophrénie, hein.
C'est un long débat. La recherche ne semble pas conclusive là-dessus. Mais je reviens des États-Unis et, à la fin, j'étais à Portland-
Aux États-Unis où c'est devenu largement légalisé.
Voilà. Portland, en tout cas, dans l'État d'Oregon, c'est autorisé. Mais la ville de Portland est une ville qui accueille des quantités invraisemblables de SDF qui sont dans des états de santé misérables, précaires.
Donc je doute fort que nos édiles publics voudraient arriver à des choses comme ça. Donc, ils-
Est-ce que les deux sont liés ? Ça, je ne suis pas sûr.
Ben en fait, ces substances sont liées entre elles.
Souvent, les consommateurs sont un peu les mêmes, hein. Donc, en l'occurrence, en Oregon et en Californie, c'est principalement une crise sur des antidouleurs, hein, la méthamphétamine, le fentanyl, etc.
Donc des antidouleurs qui ont été, entre autres, promus par des firmes pharmaceutiques.
La firme Purdue, si je me rappelle bien. Et la prescription par des médecins. Donc c'est pas lié à la consommation de cannabis de fait.
Mais les substances, en fait, lorsqu'on les normalise, peuvent avoir des effets de santé publique plutôt négatifs, hein.
Donc moi, je suis pas en faveur d'une normalisation de la consommation de tabac. Sans doute qu'il y a une différence entre-
De cannabis.
Du cannabis, pardon. Sans doute qu'il y a une différence entre décriminaliser versus autoriser, hein.
Vous pouvez avoir une politique qui vise à ne pas criminaliser la consommation. Mais c'est différent de dire : vous autorisez la consommation.
Ou leur vendre le trafic, voilà.
Voilà. Je crois d'ailleurs que les Pays-Bas sont en train de réfléchir à cet égard sur cette question de la consommation de cannabis, puisque bon, ben ça a parfois des effets inattendus.
Ça peut enrichir aussi des réseaux criminels qui vivent de ce commerce. Donc personnellement, moi, je ne suis pas en faveur d'une légalisation de comportements qui présentent en fait encore des doutes-
Mmm-hmm.
Quant à la santé mentale de la population et en particulier des adolescents.
Il y a une ambiguïté. Alors, les chiffres sont, comme vous le disiez, encore pas très conclusifs, il y a encore un petit peu de flou, mais sur
une petite minorité de la population qui, une fois exposée au THC, pourrait vraiment réveiller des épisodes schizophréniques très, très importants.
Ouais.
Et donc, puisque de base, on ne sait pas si on fait partie de cette petite minorité, il y a effectivement un risque qui existe.
Donc ça, c'est pour la question du cannabis. Bon après, il y a d'autres aspects qu'on n'a pas forcément évoqués. Il y a, contrairement au tabac, où là, on a expliqué que
le tabac n'était pas vraiment soulageant en termes d'anxiété, ne permettait pas vraiment de détendre.
C'était simplement l'addiction qui était un petit peu soulagée, voilà. Pour le cannabis, lui, a sans doute des propriétés, notamment le CBD, qui sont réellement, voilà, je sais pas quel terme employer, mais relaxantes, voilà.
Donc bon, dans un terme médical, il y a, voilà, la notion du cannabis médical qu'on peut aussi explorer, mais comme vous le disiez, ce n'est pas forcément votre spécialité.
Hum, parlons alors maintenant des objectifs en termes de santé publique dans un horizon court ou lointain. Un exemple qui est intéressant, c'est celui de la Nouvelle-Zélande, puisque vous parlez d'une génération sans tabac.
Oui, tout à fait.
La Nouvelle-Zélande a prévu d'interdire,
d'ailleurs, je dis a prévu, je ne sais pas si c'est déjà en application, mais prévu d'interdire
en dessous, à partir d'une certaine année, si vous êtes né après une certaine année, vous ne pouvez plus acheter de tabac, de paquets de tabac et vous ne pourrez plus jamais le faire.
Et l'idée, c'est que ça disparaisse de façon permanente. Est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est une idée intéressante ?
Est-ce que d'ailleurs, si vous avez suivi le dossier, est-ce que vous savez si c'est déjà en application ?
En Nouvelle-Zélande, c'est ça que-- je ne sais pas si c'est déjà en application en Nouvelle-Zélande. Je crois qu'ils approchent du end game, comme on appelle ça, beaucoup plus que nous.
Je ne saurais pas répondre à cette question-là.
D'accord. Mais sans parler précisément de la Nouvelle-Zélande-
Mais par contre, par contre-
Est-ce que l'idée vous paraît intéressante ?
Je pense que c'est une idée intéressante, mais qui est intéressante à partir du moment où vous avez atteint une prévalence suffisamment basse que pour que cette mesure soit réaliste.
N'oubliez pas qu'une mesure de réglementation, en fait, elle sera efficace si elle est implémentée.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc, peut-être que ce qu'on pourrait faire, c'est d'abord être rigoureux dans l'implémentation des réglementations qu'on prend en matière de tabac.
Oui. Vous disiez, dans les écoles, il existe des réglementations, mais elles ne sont pas vraiment enforced.
Elles ne sont pas appliquées.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc, pour répondre à la question qu'on se posait il y a un instant, donc la question de la génération sans tabac en Nouvelle-Zélande, ce sera à partir de 2025.
Donc on s'en approche, mais c'est pas encore-
C'est ça.
C'est pas encore en application. Très bien. Donc si je vous pose la question des objectifs qu'on peut se fixer en termes de santé publique vis-à-vis du tabac, précisément en Belgique, votre réponse, c'est
Oui, moi je pense-
Appliquer les réglementations qui existent déjà ?
Je pense qu'en ce qui concerne la Communauté Wallonie-Bruxelles, l'enseignement, en fait-
Mmh.
Bah, ce serait de mettre en œuvre les décisions qui ont été prises et de les mettre en œuvre, ça veut dire monitorer la situation.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut savoir où on en est si on ne monitore pas la situation ?
Mmh.
Peut-être aussi de développer une politique de promotion de la santé dans les écoles un peu plus ambitieuse. Les PSE sont certainement un acteur très important, mais ce sont des acteurs qui sont
sans doute sous-financés pour mener une politique ambitieuse dans le domaine de la promotion de la santé.
Et alors, trouver une cohérence entre des compétences qui relèvent des régions, puisque tout ce qui est assuétudes relève maintenant des régions.
Et d'autre part, le monde de l'école qui, lui, relève toujours de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Et de l'État fédéral d'ailleurs, hein, qui a, dans ses mains, une série de leviers économiques et réglementaires également.
Mmh, mmh.
Hein. Ce qui renvoie d'ailleurs à la déclaration de décembre 2022, hein, sur le plan fédéral pour une génération sans tabac, dans lequel un certain nombre de choses ont été décidées d'ailleurs.
D'accord. Je n'étais pas du tout au courant. Qu'est-ce qui a été décidé ?
Ben donc en fait, ils ont décidé d'augmenter le prix des cigarettes, d'améliorer le contrôle en matière de tabac.
Donc y a une série de mesures qui ont été décidées dans ce domaine.
Une série de mesures pour être encore un peu plus dur avec les consommateurs de tabac, mais on ne sait pas si ça va donner une génération sans tabac.
Non, non. Non, mais ça, il faut mesurer un peu l'efficacité-
Mmh.
De ces mesures. Donc il faut du monitoring. Et puis il faut une mesure d'effet quoi. Ce qui pour moi revient à la question d'évaluation de nos décisions politiques.
On prend une politique, on prend une décision, quelle qu'elle soit, peut-être qu'on a besoin de pouvoir évaluer ce qu'on fait.
Est-ce que c'est efficace ? Est-ce que c'est efficace chez tout le monde ? Hein, est-ce qu'on est équitable ? Est-ce qu'on est équitable et efficace à un coût modéré ?
Est-ce qu'il y a pas des effets secondaires ? Parce que parfois, des politiques qui sont prises ont des effets un peu inattendus, hein.
Comme ce que je vous disais, on interdit de fumer dans les écoles, à l'intérieur des écoles et pouf, le comportement se déplace à l'entrée de l'école.
Donc, je pense qu'avoir, à côté d'une politique ambitieuse, une évaluation de ce qu'on fait.
Ce qui me fait d'ailleurs penser à ce qu'on entend souvent, et je suis pas sûr que ce soit très crédible, mais je voulais le vérifier avec vous, comme quoi
la vente de tabac était finalement un income, une rentrée d'argent importante pour l'État et qu'il n'était pas forcément intéressé à voir le nombre de fumeurs diminuer.
Ouais.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité, là-derrière ?
Non. Ça, je pense que c'est un discours très simpliste.
Oui, je pense aussi.
Qu'on entend souvent, d'ailleurs dans la bouche des-
Des fumeurs.
Des fumeurs. Puisqu'ils essayent finalement, comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure, à protéger un peu leur identité sociale.
Quand ils vous disent ça, en fait, ce qu'ils vous disent : « Ben moi, je rapporte de l'argent à l'État ». En fait, c'est ce qu'on appelle une évaluation budgétaire.
Ce que vous venez de faire, c'est une évaluation purement budgétaire. Une évaluation économique, parce qu'elle va vous dire : « Ben si vous perdez huit années d'espérance de vie,
vous les multipliez par cinquante à soixante mille dollars par année et votre-
L'impact est-
Et votre compte est bon pour dire c'est une politique qui est très coût efficace.
C'est ça.
Donc, il faut pas tomber dans une évaluation purement budgétaire dans ce domaine-là.
Non. C'est sûr.
La vie a sa valeur économique, hein.
Et donc on a pu discuter de cette question à travers un prisme, voilà, sociologique, les différentes strates qui sont plus ou moins affectées, les questions de politique de santé, questions, voilà, économiques.
Est-ce qu'il y aurait encore un ou plusieurs aspects que vous souhaiteriez évoquer avant qu'on se quitte ?
Oui. Pour moi, en fait, cette question du tabagisme chez les adolescents est une sorte de prisme intéressant pour
considérer qu'on a peut-être tendance à oublier le poids et l'importance de ce groupe social que sont les adolescents.
Mmh-mmh.
Qui ont peu de poids politique, hein. En tout cas, jusqu'à dix-huit ans, ils ont pas de poids politique.
Qui vont bientôt pouvoir voter ou pas. D'ailleurs, il y a une petite interrogation là-dessus, ouais.
Oui, on en parle un petit peu. Et que, finalement, on met énormément d'argent dans les soins de santé, entre autres pour les personnes âgées, etc.
Et on peut se demander dans quelle mesure la santé des adolescents est un groupe prioritaire, en fait. Et mon sentiment, quand je regarde la,
en particulier, les politiques de promotion de la santé dans les écoles, c'est que c'est pas le cas.
Mmh.
Or, les adolescents, ben c'est les adultes de demain, hein.
C'est les travailleurs de demain, hein. Et donc mon-
Et pourquoi est-ce que ce n'est pas le cas ?
Eh bien, mon hypothèse, c'est d'une part, parce que ce n'est pas un public électoral qui rapporte aux partis politiques, hein.
Vous êtes en avant-dernière année de secondaire, vous ne votez pas, hein.
Oui.
Et donc, pourquoi les responsables politiques s'intéresseraient-ils au bien-être des adolescents dans les écoles si ce n'est pas un public électoralement qui rapporte ?
Vous allez me dire : « C'est cynique ». Mais d'un point de vue purement sciences politiques, on sait que les partis s'intéressent principalement à ceux qui votent.
Au court terme, oui.
Ce qui explique un glissement de l'attention des politiques vers les personnes âgées.
Mmh.
Hein. Les personnes âgées constituent un public de choix pour les partis politiques parce que les personnes âgées votent.
Que les personnes âgées sont un groupe important. Moi, ma question, c'est : est-ce que les adolescents ne pourraient pas retrouver une part un peu plus honorable dans le débat politique, dans les ressources qui leur sont octroyées ?
Certainement dans le monde scolaire, hein. Et on voit qu'à certains égards, il y a des efforts très importants qui sont faits, par exemple via le Pacte d'excellence et des choses comme ça.
Mais je pense que dans le domaine de la santé des enfants à l'école,
on pourrait faire mieux. Et sans doute que leur donner un meilleur poids politique pourrait être une manière d'amener les hommes politiques, les hommes et les femmes politiques, pardon, à s'y intéresser.
Si on leur donne un poids politique et que parmi ces adolescents, il y a des fumeurs, peut-être que ces adolescents fumeurs ont surtout envie qu'on leur donne une marge de liberté et qu'on les écrase moins-
Ouais.
En ce qui concerne leur consommation de tabac.
Je suis pas sûr que tous les fumeurs sont heureux d'être fumeurs, hein.
Les adolescents fumeurs-
Peut-être que les adolescents fumeurs-
Ont tendance à assumer, ouais.
Ben bon, la majorité des adolescents dans les écoles sont non-fumeurs, Dieu merci.
Vous avez-
Et ben vous pouvez avoir des politiques de promotion et de prévention de la santé qui aident les fumeurs à arrêter de fumer.
Mh.
Et au total, tout le monde s'en ressort mieux. D'abord, les finances du fumeur lui-même, hein. Y a une chose que peut-être les écoles oublient à propos des adolescents fumeurs.
Vous savez que c'est une cause majeure d'absentéisme à l'école ?
Ah non, dites-moi. Parce qu'ils sont-- Ah oui, parce que les fumeurs sont plus malades que les autres.
Ils ont plus de problèmes de santé, en fait.
Oui, oui.
Et donc-
À l'école et dans le milieu professionnel, oui.
Oui. Oui, mais si on parle des adolescents, c'est à l'école. En fait, c'est une cause majeure d'absentéisme dans les écoles.
Et donc, finalement, s'intéresser au tabac, c'est revenir au métier principal de l'école qui est d'éduquer, en fait.
Mmh.
Qui est de former, qui est de préparer.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Très bien. Vincent Lorant, merci beaucoup pour ces Septante Minutes en ce qui concerne le tabac ici en Belgique, à travers le prisme de la sociologie.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Salut.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ce premier épisode de cette sixième saison. J'en reviens toujours pas. Sixième saison.
J'ai sorti un édito qui vous fait une petite rétrospective sur le podcast et sur son futur, comme c'est devenu un petit peu la tradition.
N'hésitez pas à aller l'écouter. N'hésitez pas à m'envoyer vos retours sur cet épisode ou à m'envoyer vos suggestions pour de futurs invités.
Tous les liens sont en description. Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut !